ladies and gentlemen it's jenny mullen
i wanted to have a really dramatic
reveal she loves
she loves a dramatic entrance i mean my
god
you know what i feel like i've equated
zooms
like when people hide or they're in that
back screen
to people popping up from behind the
couch and being like by the way i've
been here the whole time and you're like
ah
what did i say what did i do i'm such a
fan
of your dictator lunches jenny it makes
me feel so good as a mom and it makes me
feel like i
i could do this too and i could step up
my game
and i know that it really makes a
difference with kids like this stuff
means a lot to them and i think you're
showing us all
something he and he said it was an
extension of your love
oh did you say that i might have i don't
know what i'm saying he's just saying
that so that he can get out of making
the lunches
yeah i really cannot make these things
ever
so i'm just glad she's i'm just glad she
does it and i don't have to
well speaking of like jenny will you
teach us how to do this we all want to
be like you and
be uh extenders of our love for our
children
i would love to take you through one i
actually i have one
i happen to have one right here um
so what i've done today is i wanted to
do a lunch that sort of
spoke to uh you know the
happiness and excitement of this new
presidency
and what's happening in our nation so
the uh the dictator lunch that we're
gonna go with today
is the new world lunch i like to give
them all a name
um what i'm going to start with i have
some raspberries up top and this is like
a trick that i don't know i don't know
how i came up with this
but i took this is the benadryl syringe
from just like your you know
your local benadryl children's better
that you have in the house your local
not your international benadryl
the location always go by local
so i'm gonna swish some yogurt into each
of these little
raspberries it's kind of an easy way for
them to
eat the yogurt and not have it all over
themselves as well jenny i think
my syringe might have come from the vet
okay that works too that just adds
another level of excitement
that's a huge syringe that's for a great
thing we need one of those at home just
to like scare the kids
because just like instead of a timeout
you just pull that out and you're like
don't mess with me i mean it's pretty
okay if if everything about
parenting isn't about like leverage all
the time
you know i'm so excited when there's
like
i have some leverage and like the bribes
i
i hate when i've run out of bribes in
the house ah um okay so for the next
little compartment i love this planet
box they give me all these little
nice compartments i have a unity salad i
always like to push the envelope a
little bit like i know
he might not eat this kale but i want
the repetition i want him to keep seeing
it because eventually
i'm going to win in the end also color
matters
whenever i'm like making a bento box or
something for my kids i try so hard to
balance out the colors
you know going on right now i feel like
i'm feeling the love from everybody
around me and um i have some wasabi peas
just to keep it interesting
but i'm gonna but i'm gonna hide the
wasabi with these little
beet love chips all right i've got beet
heart okay
and now i'm going for in the united
states
of america i have an american flag
sandwich which
for you guys i did the jam because i
think it looks prettier
but i'm sort of hardcore with the sugar
that i'm putting in these so i probably
to be honest with you would have done
sun butter instead of jelly underneath
these bananas
by the way i love sun butter this little
guy
is from a small business in new york a
small little baker called spots
and i'm just going to put him in the
middle because i love the compartment in
the middle it's like
sometimes i just put goji berries
sometimes it's
i don't know a scoop of sun butter but
today i love my favorite is when i have
something that actually fits it
and um today i happen to have a cupcake
on hand
it's this is you know that's it
there you go everybody look at what
jenny inspired me to make
i love that you name them all
and obviously um have you
ever considered like a lovely coffee
table book for your kids when they grow
up of
every picture of these from your
instagram come on this is amazing
i love the aftershocks of what my kids
do to these lunches that's sort of my
favorite part
and they haven't seen american pie yet
so what they do to the lunches
is still pg yes i heard you guys said
it's a good thing that you have boys
um because when they see that believe me
i have things my girls are going to see
and they you know i've tried to like
forewarn them but i'm like yeah
the reason i'm so like chased now is
because i tried everything and i found
myself here
and how funny is that we love that yeah
there's nothing there's nothing but g
rated left in us i totally
get that i know it's true all the r and
the x is just gone
that's so true well g also is
for games and i
love games so much we just had game show
week
on the show and i grew up watching them
i'm a big fan
tell me everything about cherries wild
by the way that was a stellar
segue drew if i may say so myself g
is for games and g is for good
transition
thank you hi
i i'm obsessed with game shows i feel
like when i was growing up it was
another great time
and i would stay home from school sick
and watch the prices right and all the
daytime game shows and it was like
it was heaven for me i love games uh
i love getting excited giving away other
people's money i get
very excited giving away other people's
money and
and yeah i just uh you know i felt like
it'd be a fun fit for me and
my good friends at fox uh you know came
to me and they
had this great idea they're
collaborating with pepsi for their wild
cherry brand and they have the show
cherries while it's a giant slot machine
crazy crazy slot machine and you've got
a pair of uh
a pair comes on a team of two every
episode
and they do pop culture trivia questions
uh to earn
spins on the slot machine and they can
win 250 000
and it's crazy and it's awesome and it's
fun and i had a blast and
yeah it was so much fun i'm really
excited for this show i just think it's
gonna be
really huge and i'm gonna be there on
the feeder
and you know what you guys h is for host
and uh i don't know how i got into this
weird sesame street
letter transition thing but now i'm just
riding it into the sunset and uh
certainly uh jenny you get the letter
m for best mom oh thank you
jenny mullen jason
[Applause]
thank you guys terry's wild there's
sundays at 7
6 central on fox
[Music]
you